*original content*
shut the fuck up
*music plays*
skrattar du
förlorar du
maNEEEeeEEEeEen
hey mannen, do you want some? do you want some skratta?
Huh, are you gonna have some skratta?
*Laughs like an old man*
Come on - Come to papa Felix and you're gonna get some SKRATTAR DU, FÖRLORAR DU! Welcome to YouTube's favorite show
the rule is simple: if you laugh you lose. And you can't do either one of them
Challenge accepted by leaving a like on this video right now.
(???)
*Piano music*
We sOo Lit
*song* I'm so lit right now
*song* OK OK OK
WE SO LIT
DABLIKETHIS
WESOLIT
EATLIKETHIS
SHE'S MY BEST FRIEND
I'M SO LIT RIGHT NOW, OK, O-
Bish that, did not even close to rhyme what the actual f*ckery are you trying to say
*laughs*
Love the tune though it's hella lit
Pewds: WE SO LIT
-MERCH RIGHT NOW
I'M SO LIT RIGHT NOW, OK, OK, OK
WE SO LIT
Alright, now let's move on *video* it's hard to just sleep when, you're tired because people are tired most of the time.
Hi I'm Kesha love you so much
aww thanks! Can i give you a hug? No thanks.
Please.. No thanks. A little one, yeah no thanks
*laughing awkwardly*
I dont know who that was!
Yeah, you did jerry come on
oh brilliant
I like how, Jerry is still living on in the Seinfeld Show
In real life and as always brofist everyone, oh?
my, god
*title* me brofooting a picture of pewdiepie for 12 minutes and 29 seconds
*it keeps going*
Well it looks like, my job here is done this video will now play on for the rest of the video. Enjoy
skrattar du förlorar du, i have literally anything else to do.
*please come back*
I'm joking i'm joking stop crying, does he actually though
oh my god
I'm losing brain cells every second let's move on, *singing* we so lit! dab like this *dabs*
it's catchy SHUT UP!!
Shut up, it's catchy, like Ke$ha
Okay, alright i'm sure you've seen this playlist on YouTube called:
"Instant Regret Clicking this Playlist (Memes)"
It's got that stupid picture of that guy's face
Making their face like *AARRR*
I'm sure you've seen it YouTube has been shelling this playlist more than anything else in the entire website.
For some reason this playlist is god and it rules upon this wretched land is he'll?
Actually live streaming right now, sorry i just saw dark toels.. is he playing with his feet?
Hey, hey hey it's the leg man no one really turns in 20 streams i do but i feel like
Why, not both alright
PewDiePie??
come on felix
it's..
It's surprisingly difficult to just keep your leg in a camera because you have to try and tilt the whole camera away from you
BOOHOO BOOHOO
Okay, where was that yes the instant regret play clicking this, how
Do i speak playlist thank you. This is my job this is i have to describe things you are welcome it gets millions of views.
And i am now going to react to this playlist as a poor attempt to
Get in recommended to these videos so that i can get millions of views without any form of..
Ehh..
Talent and original content. *high pitched voice* Oh he's self-aware that's so funny i'm gonna leave a like on this video right now
Don't forget to buy the merch as well thank you. Now let's say.. let's get into this playlist shall we?
Shawn White for the cold
To, take down on you move and gets it the second 1440
Double mctwist 1260 shot was broad moorhead will it be enough
Pretty solid edit but did it make me skratta but don't make me laugh i mean literally
don't that's the point of the game
*laughs*
Okay, let's keep going
Stop the hammering stop the hammering out there who's got a hammer (Pewds: okay, that one was good)
congratulations but i didn't skratta get out of here
Do you know what that means?
And let me teach you a lesson, (Pewds: Lemme guess he's going to throw the glass, but it's going to hit someone else)
Oh wow, what is this dolan dark?
They're too fast how do i supposed to react to this
*Oh PeWdS yOu jUsT rEpLaY tHe ViDeO* yes cuz, it's lilly six seconds and i need to process what happened
I Still don't understand my god so annoying this is just annoying
People like this? People like this shit?
my god(Barack Obama: hey, guys this is Barack)
- octavia and the johns hopkins i want you to know i love memes i love them all right thank you thank you mr.
Cue the trump memes jumping
yeah
whats wrong with him
I love refrigerators (pewds: oh, my, god   le random)
This playlist sucks and you suck for liking it okay i'm gonna
Be the first one to say it that's right i mean it's not for me to have a contrarian
Opinion it is my genuine duty to review
This as a meme reviewer the way it truly needs to be reviewed you are welcome what do you
Want me to sit here and laugh and be like
that was funny cuz i can do that
i can't i get literally can't
i can't even force myself
When you have it on your hand you really feel, like, you're suspended
so this is just OHhHhH
(More OhHhH'S)
oh, (Intangible) the heights to which he'll go to
(ohhh) are you alright richard?
(laughs)
(screams)
(more screaming)
wooow wow wow wow w-(laughs)
You, did it dolan dark. You did it hurray for you, good good for you
Actual a-apple ad.. you best be joking hey, what you doing on your computer what's a computer?
oh my god wHaT's A cOmPuTeR wE'rE ApPlE, wE tRy tO iNnOvAtE
In ThE FuTuRe nO oNE wILl KnOw  A cOMpu-skdskdsk
This is painful this pain
its inflicted upon me with this paylaylist that i can't articulate myself help me
Hey, look, a video, longer than six seconds how 'bout that everyone wow
It's actually so relatable.
Whenever I was in school, I was always like,
"Alright, let's just get this done, and then you can go home and play video games."
And look where that got me! Hooray!
Yay for me!
Alright, what is this? An unlisted video? Wow!
What's he doing?
hEhEhEhehee
Is he gonna get hit by a car
No, that was it that was it that was all the memes
are you, kidding, me it's not funny your shitty, memes aren't funny unless someone gets hurt if he doesn't get hit
By a car then what's the point
What what's the point of that seriously have, we fallen that low. Have, we stoop that low
That no one will even be close to death?
Then, why is it funny, why is it funny then, what was funny about that?
Nothing, was funny about that?
Nothing is funny unless someone gets hurt, so my mom try to be cute
make, these little thanksgiving snacks here she saw on uhh
Pinterest this is what they actually came out?
oh that's great fine fine?
instant regret by clicking playlist you got me one time, what do you want an award i will not laugh at the next one
ohHhHhHh
(bleep) Get out of the way bus!
yes!
What a savage bus everybody
then now it leaves wow hooray hooray, well i think that's a good time as any to end it here wow wE So LiT
DaB lIkE tHiS
Hope you guys, enjoyed this video if you, did leave a like and if you didn't laughs, make, sure you leave a like as
Well anyway, also make sure to subscribe
Everybody, check out the instant regret playlist shout out to that wonderful playlist i'm now
Going to end this video with something out of context because literally anything out of context is extremely hilarious
How about maybe a vsauce meme?